let's start with their box office
appearance King Ghidorah is a tree
headed dragon kaiju who first appeared
in the 1964 Godzilla film Ghidorah the
three-headed monster widely considered
to be Godzilla's arch-nemesis King
Ghidorah made his first debut in
Ghidorah the three-headed monster where
he arrived on earth inside a meteor and
prepared to destroy it just as he had
done to Venus thousands of years in the
past
he was later shown as being a pawn of
alien races like the zillions and nebula
a millions as they used to him to try
and invade and conquer earth while the
American King Ghidorah who is also
dubbed as monster zero titanic Ghidorah
or just simply Ghidorah is a giant
extraterrestrial three-headed dragon die
kaiju created by legendary pictures that
first appeared in a 2019 film Godzilla
king of the monsters as one of the two
primary antagonists the appearance of
this monster in the movie was given a
good reception by both film critics and
a die-hard fans of kaiju it was also the
first time that many new monster movie
enthusiasts came to know about this epic
creature now we shall compare the
origins of these two versions of
Ghidorah toe host King Ghidorah has
traditionally been depicted as an evil
destructive creature from outer space
although his origin has varied
throughout his appearances in the show a
serious King Ghidorah is an alien dragon
said to have attacked Venus under his
own power many thousands of years ago
wiping out the planet's entire
civilization he later then attacked
earth but was repelled by Earth's
monsters and at some point of time he
was taken control by the zillions and
used as a pawn in their invasion of
Earth and later by the other aliens the
most reverse incarnation of King
Ghidorah returns the character to his
original roots as a villainous
extraterrestrial life-form according to
information recorded from ancient
methodological texts by aileenchen
Ghidorah arrived on earth during the
planners primordial ages an outlier
amongst Earth's giant monsters it
quickly established itself as a rival
alpha 2
Zella numerous methodological deities
such as the hydra from greek mythology
and the rainbow serpent from the
aboriginal australian religion are
credited as misremembered encounters
with Ghidorah by ancient civilizations
Godzilla and Ghidorah battle each other
several times before they took their
fight to Antarctica which resulted in
Ghidorah being buried and the ice and
Godzilla's victory so regarding the size
of these two odorous they are as follows
the Showa King Ghidorah has a height of
100 meters or 330 feet tall and is said
to be 55 times that of a human whose
average height is 1.8 meters tall are
almost 25 to 30 storeys in height if we
take buildings in comparison so in his
weight of 30,000 metric tons being
equivalent to 6,000 African elephants
and his wingspan is 150 meters this
monster is extremely gigantic the
biggest dinosaur will be nowhere near as
tall long or heavy has to show Ghidorah
even with his ginormous size he can
still fly super fast and fight with
speed and agility that defies the laws
of physics
most of us Ghidorah on the other hand is
even bigger in all respects as compared
to the Showa version he is almost 159
meters tall which is more than 50%
taller than the former making him as
tall as 88 humans and if we compare two
buildings he would stand between 39 and
40 eight stories high his weight in the
movie is a hundred and forty-one
thousand 56 tons which is almost equal
to a hundred twenty-eight thousand
metric tons therefore making him 4.2
times heavier and also equivalent to
twenty five thousand six hundred
elephants the data on wingspan is not
officially given but by the looks of it
in the movie it is clearly more than
twice his height therefore being in the
range of anywhere between three hundred
and four meters or between a thousand
1300 from tip to tip
there are a wide variety of powers for
both the de Shoah and the monster was
gay Doris the shower version can fly up
to speeds of Mach 3 in the Earth's
atmosphere by flapping its gigantic
wings and exceed this while flying
through space reaching a speed of Mach
400 whoa that's almost five hundred
thousand kilometers per hour but King G
Doris arguably most famous ability is
the golden lightening bolt like gravity
beams that he spits from his tree mouths
these beams are roughly equal in power
to God's earth atomic breath and are
capable of causing large-scale
explosions when fired at buildings King
Ghidorah can produce hurricane-force
wings by flapping his wings which are
capable of blowing away buildings and
knocking over other kaiju of their feet
King Ghidorah had the ability to
generate what appeared to be magnetic
fields that vary in strength from time
to time while it was never stated
directly what purpose they served in the
state of that day was somehow connected
to his powers as for most of us we Doris
Powers firstly his skin was covered with
traces of gold that acted as a conductor
that carried bio electrical currents
throughout his body he had
electroreceptive molecular biology and
could conduct electrical currents make
water vapor heat up to extreme levels
and create localized storm systems are
the worldly tempest of thunder and
lightning and also hurricane like winds
hey Doris massive and powerful wings
enable him to fly at great speeds over
long distances Ghidorah could shoot
golden gravity beams which are
concentrated beams of electricity from
his mouths where Ghidorah had absorbed
enough amounts of power he could project
gravity beams from the tips of his wings
the most unique power however was that
using the radiation from Roland's
volcano Ghidorah was able to regenerate
the head that was decapitated by
Godzilla almost instantaneously he was
also able to absorb energy from Godzilla
by sucking it using his mouths
now let's dive in into the body designs
so looking at Showa Ghidorah he seems to
be oversimplified by modern standards
but let's not judge the pioneer of space
dragon designs
anyway this version has tree long but
thick next at spot one head each with
two long horns and three or four smaller
ones
his next emerge from a fat abdomen that
also has two thick legs with claws that
seem to look like a cross between a
human and a rhinos foot he also has two
tails which are longer than his necks
and he bought end up in clubs with a lot
of spikes that grow outwards his back is
also covered with a singular row of
spines that run down from his necks now
we come to the wings they were very
different from any living thing that
exists today which is good as it gives
him the unique fantasy dragon look
anyway the wings had six digits which
would have been like fingers growing
directly from the shoulder of the kaiju
we're asked the most of us Ghidorah is
way larger than Godzilla and each of his
necks had a row of spines going down but
the middle one had two rows of spines
when a left and right next have only one
each of his heads had a crown of horns
similar to the Heisei incarnation but
each horns longer and more curved the
horns also tend to flare depending on
kid auras current mood the middle heads
horns are noticeably larger straighter
and longer than those of the peripheral
heads Ghaderi still has his traditional
twin tails with spikes at their tips
that can rattle as an intimidation
display like a rattlesnake his legs are
digitigrade with avian like feet similar
to the 2001 incarnation eudorus eyes of
fiery red that seemed to glow yellow
whenever he charges up and fires his
gravity beams and his tongues are fought
like a snake guitarists wings are also
much larger and more back light in
appearance than most incarnations and
they can also act as four limbs to
support his massive body so now let's
head on into the monsters durability and
weaknesses they show a version they're
more than a match for Godzilla in a
one-on-one battle he
to become overwhelmed when facing
multiple kaiju at once King Ghidorah
also tends to become confused when the
mind control of his alien masters is
severed which leaves him open and
vulnerable to attack other than that he
wasn't seen with any other weaknesses
nevertheless King Ghidorah is extremely
durable and resistant to damage to an
extent close to Godzilla
he was Stan's conventional weaponry with
no noticeable effect and can even shrug
off point-blank blast from Godzilla's
atomic breath King Ghidorah attempts to
use his durability to his advantage as
he often prefers to escape from a battle
that he can't win before he suffers more
injuries than necessary so even though
most of us Ghidorah is extremely
powerful he has several notable
weaknesses for one he could not
withstand the thermonuclear pulses
released by Godzilla in his burning form
which incinerated his wings and heads
within seconds but hey nothing can
withstand that and also since Ghidorah
physical structure was that of an
airborne creature he was not entirely
suited to move underwater Ghidorah
struggled to fight back and got his left
head easily decapitated nevertheless
most of us Ghidorah see golden scales
made him highly impervious to any form
of weaponry he was also able to
withstand a full force charge from both
Rodin and Godzilla even the sheer power
of a power-up Godzilla's atomic breath
couldn't cause any noticeable damage to
him furthermore after the destruction of
his entire body G Doris middle head
continued to struggle while in
Godzilla's jaws only to be destroyed
when the g-man files his last atomic
breath yeah now we know each and
everything about these two versions of
the kaiju space dragon in short they
were both from space and both came to
earth to subjugate the planet and
destroy everything in it they both were
enormous in size but most of us guitar
was way bigger and the designs of his
body was more realistic in comparison to
the old Scheuer version as for their
powers both of them sport gravity beams
and both were extremely durable but ash
overtakes the women with his mop four
hundred speed in outer space although
with the super fast regeneration ability
the most of us Ghidorah is unique
compared to any of the other ones anyway
the choice is up to you guys to pick the
winner of this comparison do the needful
and commend your thoughts and while
you're at it give us some of your ideas
for the next videos and at the same time
click that subscribe button and bell
button